le corps d'un virus a mise au chômage de
nombreux travailleurs à travers le monde
alors certains ont décidé de s'adapter à
la crise en fabriquant des masques de
protection
illustration au mexique ou en catcheur
réputé passe désormais ses journées dans
un atelier de couture
le portrait est signé luca tueur et léo
mattei
[Musique]
il a troqué les masques de combat pour
les masques de protection
c'est la surprenante reconversion de
raphaël médina une star de la lucha
libre et le catch mexicain dans la
capitale on le connaît plus tôt sous son
nom de lutter veneno alias poison
lorsque les mesures ont été prises pour
suspendre les activités des groupes
automatiquement les réunions les
spectacles de lucha libre et qui attire
la foule ont dû s'interrompre également
normalement mon commerce tourne autour
de la lucha libre et mais grâce aux
masques de protection j'ai pu m'adapter
et j'arrive à payer mon loyer et toutes
mes factures courantes
j'arrive à subsister malgré cette crise
mondiale poison est habitué à la machine
à coudre
depuis des années il fabrique ses
propres masques élément capital de cette
tradition de lutter le masque fait
partie de son costume comme de son
identité de combattants les matériaux
que j'utilise je m'en sert
habituellement pour fabriquer des
costumes de lutter slips caleçons ou
genouillère toutes les boutiques de
tissus sont fermés mais moi en tant que
lutteur professionnel j'ai la chance
d'avoir tout le matériel nécessaire à la
confection de masques de lucha libre et
ce type de masque
je vais livrer ses masques aux vendeurs
de volailles du marché certains
commerçants du quartier lui commandent
fréquemment des dizaines de pièces le
travail de poison est apprécié par ceux
qui préfèrent les masques personnalisé
aux masques chirurgicaux classique au
marché du point presque tous les
commerçants porte mais masque dans le
quartier je suis le distributeur numéro
un
voilà je t'amène tes nouveaux masques ok
merci beaucoup
ces masques sont plus pratiques que les
ordinaires je respire mieux je transpire
- et même si je dois aller porter toute
la journée ils ne méritent pas en
attendant l'arrivée d'un traitement ou
d'un vaccin
les habitants de ce quartier de mexico
sont nombreux à se tourner vers poison
pour lutter contre le virus
[Musique]